I think it was a mixture of things
really obviously the main one being the
lack of leadership from the club itself
it shed no light really on it what it
believes is the right or wrong thing
from this case and has made very little
comment on it and I need to establish
what was happening they wouldn't tell me
what was happening and I think I find it
without really well now that what was
their response when you resigned then I
haven't spoken to him since since that
but I mean I supposed to people at club
before I did so I made it clear that I
felt that he should rebuild his career
by all means but not in the football
shirt of teaming let down so badly I
think yeah I do believe in
rehabilitation a but i believe to do
that you have to move on and move away
and i think it would be both good for
obviously first and foremost a victim
but secondly mr. Evans himself and the
club because the club's reputation is so
clearly in the gospel at the moment so
just to be clear you believe that Chad
Evans should be allowed to play for
another team just not Sheffield United I
think he should have the right to
rebuild rebuild his career I mean this
isn't really about you know just saying
like that city can never play football
again and I think that's been some of
the confusion I think that you know the
silence that we've heard from the the FA
in the PFA and and the club itself has
been the compute confusion should a
person be able to walk back into the job
well no was a career can you walk back
into the same place of work and I would
suggest if you're going to say well you
do believe in rehabilitation which I do
and then in that case you have to say
well it should be another place of work
and not the one not simply walking out
prison and into the same club that he
was working out before a pork or some
would say that chair Evans has quite an
exceptional role here's for many
particularly younger boys a role model
and the fact he's actually expressed no
remorse for what was alleged have
happened means but he shouldn't be
allowed to play even for another team
well I'm hoping that things will change
on that count I mean it's not looking
flavor I think one thing he could have
done would be terrible abuse you know
that lindsey graham charlie webster and
jessica ennis-hill were getting over
social media that was an ideal time for
him to come forward and and defend them
because after all they've they've
resigned their position in all honesty
so I'm not sure if that's ever going to
happen if it doesn't happen it's not up
to me to go around and say you can never
work in football again it took to those
clubs to take that decision then I'm
saying as a Sheffield United patron that
he can't be at my club if he's at my
club I really cannot stay there it's a
it's a as you say it's quite a complex
situation this because of course the
club said that they were asked by the
professional footballing ability to
accept head Evans back for training and
they were obliged to that as his last
place of employment but you'll do you
think perhaps they shouldn't have even
done that no I don't think we should
have done that I think Gordon Pele's is
severely misled in expecting sheffield
united to have to do that I don't know
whether it was a request or it was
something stronger than a request but I
think the first thing that should have
happened would be to get him away from
you know the core be let down so badly